字幕: Tsubasa Kinoshita
校正: Hiroko Kawano
大学４年生の６月
私の人生は 大きく変わりました
汗が止まらなくなったり
少し歩いただけで 息切れがしたり
動悸がしたりしたのです
体調不良を覚え 病院に行った私は
完治することがない病気の
バセドウ病だと診断されました
バセドウ病は
首の前側にある甲状腺という器官から
甲状腺ホルモンが
過剰に作られてしまう病気です
甲状腺ホルモンは 体の新陳代謝を促し
体の働きを活発にするホルモンです
ホルモンの量が過剰になると
「寝ていてもジョギングしている」
と例えられるほど
体の働きが活発になりすぎてしまい
様々な症状が現れます
私は特に汗が止まらなくなる症状に悩みました
周りの人から汚いと思われたくなくて
大学では 人と話すことが
怖くなってしまいました
私は 大学の卒業式の日のことを
忘れることができません
「４月からどこで働くの？」
友達同士が目を輝かせながら話していました
「私は先生になるよ」という友達がいました
「ずっと働きたいと思っていた
ブライダルの世界で働くんだよ」
そう笑顔で話す友達もいました
私も 進路を決めて
大学を卒業すると決めていました
ですがバセドウ病によって
就職することができなくなりました
友達同士でそんな会話が飛び交っている中
自分の進路を聞かれることが怖くて
自分は何者でもなくなって
しまうことが恥ずかしくて
自分はここにいてはいけないように感じて
私は逃げるように卒業式から帰りました
私は 一番の劣等生でした
ご飯も喉を通らず
夜も眠れない日が続きました
そして私は 最終的に
うつ状態になってしまいました
とても辛い経験をしたり
自分のことが嫌いになったり
自分に自信が持てなくなったりすることは
きっと誰しもが経験することなのだと思います
でも そんな辛い出来事の中でも
私たちは 幸せのかけらを
見つけ出す力を持っています
バセドウ病になって以来
これまで私が たくさんの人たちから
もらってきたこの力を
今日は私が 皆さんにお伝えできるように
このプレゼンテーションを
今日のこの時間を
皆さんと一緒に
紡いでいきたいと思います
孤独だと思っていた私に
寄り添ってくださった方がいます
それは私の主治医の 内堀先生でした
先生は私の運命を変えてくれました
「僕も大学を卒業するとき
仕事が決まってなかったよ」と
先生はおっしゃったんです
医学部に入学するために
大学卒業後 何度も受験をしたこと
５年浪人生活を送った後
６年間大学で医学を学んだことを
私に教えてくれました
就職先が見つからず
苦しかった当時の私にとって
先生のこの言葉は 驚くほど温かく
私の胸に響きました
自分の弱みを見せてくれる大人がいることに
大きな衝撃を受けました
先生がしてくださったことは
それだけではありません
教育や福祉や医療の世界に
興味があることを話すと
どんな仕事があるか
その仕事に就くために
今私にできることは何かを
一緒になって考えてくれました
私はこれまでの人生の中で
私のためにここまで伴走してくれる大人と
出会ったことがありませんでした
「独りじゃないよ」
「一緒にどうすればいいか考えよう」
という先生の姿勢は
私を安心させてくれました
「もう少し頑張れるかもしれない」と
希望が持てるようになったんです
そして私も 一人一人と
正面から向き合える大人になりたい
そんな働き方をしたいと決めました
内堀先生は バセドウ病の
治療をしてくれた人です
ですが それ以上に
なりたい私を教えてくれた
とても大切な人です
現在もバセドウ病の治療は続けていますが
治療を進める中で
汗が止まらなくなる症状や
息切れがする症状も和らぎ
就職活動も無事 乗り切ることができました
先生に手伝ってもらいながら 私が選んだ道
それは教育福祉の仕事でした
今は主に発達障害のあるお子様と
関わらせてもらっています
私は今でも 内堀先生を目指して働いています
私はバセドウ病になり
就職活動がうまくいきませんでした
同級生と同じように就職できなかった私は
これまで育ててくれた両親に
迷惑しかかけていないと思い
私は ここにいてはいけないんだと
考えるようになりました
私は 生きていてはいけないと
ですが この世の中で自分の存在を
否定してもいい人なんているのでしょうか？
私は 病気のことで自分を
これ以上否定し続けたくありません
悔しかったんです
一歩前に進みたかったんです
バセドウ病になったからこそ出会える幸せを
私は探したいです
また 以前ほど汗をかかなくなった私は
人と話せることが こんなにも
幸せなことなんだと知りました
これは病気になるまでは
感じることのなかった幸せでした
病気になる前以上に
人と会いたいと思いました
バセドウ病がきっかけとなって
内堀先生という素敵な先生と
出会うことができました
そしてそんな出会いを
もっともっと積み重ねていきたいと思い
私はいろんな人に会いに行く旅を 始めました
私はこれまで 生き方を変えられる
出会いを何度も経験しました
今日はあと２つの出会いを
皆さんにご紹介したいと思います
初めに バセドウ病を含めた
甲状腺疾患の患者会である
「おしゃべり会」に参加しました
最初はどんな場所か不安で
何度も入り口まで行っては
引き返すことを繰り返していました
最後には なんとか勇気を振り絞って
会場に入ることができました
そこでは患者さんとスタッフの皆さんが
円形になって座り
コーヒーやお茶を飲みながら
治療を進める上での不安や心配事を
お話しされていました
私はそこで これまで感じていた
悲しい気持ちや悔しい気持ちを
すべて話しました
同級生と同じように就職できないことが
辛かったです
誰にも相談できず
独りぼっちだと感じていました
両親に ごめんなさいと思って生きていました
すると 同じ甲状腺の病気のある
スタッフの皆さんが
「それは 辛かったね」と
肯きながらゆっくりと
私の話しを聞いてくれたんです
私の心配とは裏腹に
そこはとても優しい場所でした
私はこの日 独りじゃないんだ
という安心感に包まれました
そして これまで感じていた
孤独から解放されました
本当に嬉しかったです
独りじゃないということが
これほどまで心強く
温かいことなんだと私は知りました
また スタッフの皆さんからは
バセドウ病の私だから
できることがあると学びました
辛い経験を こんな形で使える
ということに 私は衝撃を受けました
「私もこんな風に
自分の辛かった経験を使いたい」
そんな気持ちを
スタッフの皆さんからもらいました
今では私も おしゃべり会の
スタッフの一人になり
日々 同じ病気の患者さんからお話を伺っています
相談室に入って来るときに
元気のなさそうな表情をしていた患者さんが
「今日はおしゃべり会に来られて
本当によかったです」
「同じ病気の人の話を伺えて安心しました」と
笑顔で帰って行く瞬間を
見るときの感動は本当に大きいです
こんな活動ができているのは
バセドウ病になったからこそだと感じています
バセドウ病の私だからできることがあると
患者さんや仲間のスタッフから
教えてもらいました
バセドウ病になったことで
病気のある子供たちへの教育について
もっと学びたいと思い
私は次に ある講演会に参加します
講演をされたのは 副島先生という先生です
先生は 病院の中にある学級の先生です
先生の講演が終わった後の質問タイム
１人の人工呼吸器をつけた
男子学生さんが手を挙げました
「僕の病気より もっとしんどい
病気の人がいるから
僕が辛いとか しんどいとか言うのは
違うと思うのですが」
その男の人は言いました
皆さんにも 自分の気持ちを
閉じ込めてしまった経験はありませんか？
私も同じです
私自身も
バセドウ病よりも大変な病気があるから
しんどいと思ったらいけないと
自分の気持ちに
ふたをしてしまうことがありました
質問に対する先生の答えはこうでした
「質問してくれてありがとうございます
周りの人と自分を 比べなくていいと思います
自分の気持ちを大切になさってください」
私は思わず涙が出ました
講演会の中で先生が
何度もおっしゃっていたのは
どんな気持ちも 自分の大切な
気持ちだということです
辛いと感じた気持ちは
誰とも比べなくていい
辛いと感じた気持ちを
もっと自分の中で大切にしてもいい
そう 私は先生から学ばせてもらいました
毎日の生活の中で
自分の気持ちをなかったものに
してしまうことはありませんか？
でも 私たちはもっと 自分の気持ちを
大切にしていいのだと思います
私たちはもっと
辛いと感じた自分の気持ちを
素直に受け止めていいのだと思います
どんな気持ちも自分の
大切な気持ちだと知ることができたのは
バセドウ病のおかげです
私は バセドウ病です
どうしてバセドウ病に
なってしまったんだろう？
バセドウ病になったから
私の人生はこんなにも
悪くなってしまったんだと
ずっと思っていました
ですが バセドウ病になって失ったものよりも
バセドウ病が与えてくれたものの方が
多いと私は気づきました
バセドウ病が私の人生を豊かに
してくれていたことに 私は気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそ
人と話せることがこんなにも
幸せなことなんだと気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそ
たくさんの素敵な方々と出会えました
人の幸せのために
自分の命を燃やしている大人が
いることを知りました
バセドウ病だからこそ
一見悲しい出来事が人の役に立てる力を
持っていると知りました
バセドウ病だからこそ
自分の気持ちをもっと大切にしても
いいんだって気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそ
この学びを 今日皆さんに届ける機会を
いただくことができました
バセドウ病だからこそ
できることが数え切れないほどあると
今は信じています
皆さんは 「だからこそ」の前に
どのような言葉が入りますか？
私はその言葉の中に
無限の可能性が
秘められていると信じています
「だからこそ」という言葉を私にくれたのは
「動静脈奇形」という病気のある
河除静香さんです
『顔ニモマケズ』という本の中で
静香さんが話されていた言葉を
紹介させてください
「もし 今の状態が保証されるなら —
子どもがいて 主人がいて
顔の症状があったからこそ
出会えた人たちとの関係が保証されるなら ー
顔の症状はない方が良いです
ただ 今の自分になるために
この顔の症状が必要とされるなら
それはあって良かったと思います」
[『顔ニモマケズ』水野敬也著 2017年 p. 49]
静香さんのこの言葉から
バセドウ病だからこそという
生き方をしたいと決めました
今でも私は バセドウ病だから辛い
と感じる日があります
だからこそなんて
考えられないほど辛いことが
これから起こるかもしれません
でも その時その時に
心に浮かんでくる気持ちを
今は大切にしたいです
悲しい気持ちは
人の痛みを想像する力を
私に与えてくれました
悔しい気持ちは
前に一歩進む勇気を私に与えてくれました
どんな気持ちも なかったものに
しなくていいと 私は学びました
「辛い 頑張れない」と
自分の心が教えてくれたときは
「そんな日もあるよね」と
自分の心に 耳を傾けたいと思っています
これからもバセドウ病になったからこそ
バセドウ病だからこそ
できたことや出会えた人を探し続けたいです
これまでの辛い出来事の中に
そして これから
出くわすかもしれない困難の中に
だからこそできる活動や
だからこそ出会える人を
皆さんも一緒に探してみませんか？
最後に もう一度聞かせてください
あなたの「だからこそ」は 何ですか？
ありがとうございました
（拍手）